what is the best tool to give others
remote help something where I can walk
someone through a particular task track
I feel you I always end up in the phone
with my mom yelling no don't click that
button click this icon but there are a
few good tools for giving remote advice
on a Windows or Mac computer one of the
best is called teamviewer when both
computers have the app installed you can
take control of the other person's
computer and remotely show them how to
do something or just do what they ask
you to how do I open the app thing
chrome remote desktop is another option
but both of these are free and very easy
to set up skype also has a screen share
feature that lets you share your screen
and video chat at the same time it can
be very helpful but there is a drawback
you can only share your own screen you
can't actually take control of the other
person's computer if you want to help
someone in their iPad or iPhone that's
where things get a little bit harder
teamviewer does make an iphone and ipad
app but only offers limited
functionality the user has to take a
screenshot of the problem they're having
so it does have remote email setup
unfortunately with an android phone or
tablet sharing a screen involves a lot
more complicated maneuvering I hope that
helps make your tech support a little
bit easier now we could use some of your
support we're here to answer some of
your questions send them to us with the
hashtag SWS JD we might even put them in
the newspaper